du côté de la 2e circonscription nous
allons maintenant nous intéresser à
jean-guy ça use ce chevrotin est investi
par le mouvement convergence citoyenne
ce candidat se déclare entre libéral
social et social démocrate les
principaux axes de ce candidat ingénieur
de formation la démocratie citoyenne il
est au micro de mélanie poker c'est
faire en sorte que en france nous
parvenions à un niveau de satisfaction
de notre gouvernance et de nos
institutions au même niveau déjà que
ceux dont disposent les allemands avec
60 % de gens qui sont favorables à
l'heure et fiers de leurs institutions
et de leurs pratiques et puis encore
mieux donc les suisses 64% on propose
d'abord que en dernier recours dès qu'il
ya un débat
un débat qui
suscite de l'émotion comme ceux que l'on
a connu par exemple à leur travail mais
on pourrait en citer d'autres et bien ce
soit les citoyens qu'ils soient
impliqués là dessus